[Music]
in bad parenting news my future
submitted by a judge dredd parents of a
child with kidney failure refused to
donate to her because she's a girl in
China really a girl in the you [ __ ] s
not the you what's worst in China Russia
American no not Russia India yep yep oh
I didn't know that was worse you guys
said the worst and then I just went yeah
I knew people like you up
it is worse oh so the sixteen-year-old
girl from India she has been suffering
from kidney failure acute kidney failure
and they're saying that she fell
seriously ill two months ago and so she
was rushed to the hospital after
complaining of intense pain in her
mid-drift and her back and then after
doctors ran tests they discovered that
she had kidney failure and so they told
her family and the the doctors told the
family that they urgently need to find a
kidney donor or a kidney transplant and
so they're saying that well we don't
have the money and who would waste their
kidney on her just a girl like oh we
have three more just like her [ __ ] it
luzina she's because she's a girl she's
not worth the trouble they have how many
kids probably like ten I don't know how
many kids like that but they're just
saying that so the surgery will cost
$100,000 and there is no guarantee of
survival so they're saying that they
can't afford that oh my god and so after
finding this out because after the
parents like refused to even see if they
were matches but came back she refused
TV
not even water I know they've been
they've been report that the mom was
like not even fazed how old is she the
mom team what 16 years old and she can
she can understand all this that's so
[ __ ] up excuse my ignorance but um is
this like a common ideology in like
Indian culture where like the man is
more superior than the woman and we can
throw that away well they did say that
there was this want like these
statistics in this one city these two
thoughts these two hello my god my mouth
is not working these two hospitals in
this one city showed that 77 kidney
transplants have been carried out and 77
percent of those donors were women but
only eight of them were the recipients
so women are donating they're not
receiving them even more [ __ ] job what
the hell is going on India you need to
fix your [ __ ] I could kind of take a
stab at it so like in they believe in
reincarnation
right in order to achieve reincarnation
you have to first be I think or what's
the word and get to reach nirvana or
whatever you have to first be a man and
a woman has to be incarnated into a man
so then she's kind of second to want in
that concept how can you reach nirvana
or like how can you get reincarnated
without reaching Nirvana if you're not a
man so it's the hierarchy of like
creatures right like like you have
you're not like you have your caste
system and then you also have like what
do you call it like the animal like if
you if you're really karna like let's
say you [ __ ] up in your human life or
whatever you might go and become a dog
or whatever right so like in the
hierarchy of beings like women are
second to men because women have to
reincarnate into men into being able to
we reached Nirvana nirvana the
gentlemen's club you don't have to
reincarnate it yeah you're done like
once you reach it I thought your that
enlightenment that makes that could be
how this whole thing transformed you
know like in plus an interesting what
India has like a billion people right so
there's probably gonna be pockets of
like backwardness all over the country
and I don't know if everyone thinks that
way yeah but that's it's kind of like
golf it's like you're not gonna win the
US Open that's a chick like you know I'm
saying I do
this is terrible the more I hurt the
more I make fun of it man that's how I
balance my hurt so let's do ten minutes
on her now yeah that's good I know it's
so sad yeah I know
so then after people have heard about
this story they're trying to raise funds
to help her but the parents they
actually took her out of the hospital
another help they're just taking care of
her in their own home probably so
expensive yeah so they're saying that
even though there has been the the chief
minister of the relief fund has
previously helped other patients and
similar cases the parents are not trying
to get help they're just like nothing
how many siblings is she I don't know
yeah imagine you get better and then you
look at your parents [ __ ] didn't give
me a [ __ ] kidney so you actually need
at least one both are filled that's how
I lost my grandfather to kidney failure
yeah like he's you're not coming back
unless you get a new kidney he got two
kidneys both fail yeah you just use it
was completely [ __ ] yeah way to jump
too much hardcore drinker hardcore
alcohol I knew this girl in elementary
school I think we were in third grade
her fourth no fourth no third grade
there's great she ended up missing a
good chunk of third grade because she
had kidney failure and she was getting a
kidney like kidney removed yeah and so
she was just with one kidney when she
came back in fourth grade
in fifth grade not until I think ninth
grade does she have to go and get a new
kidney too because then the healthy one
the one that was left started failing on
her too
I know a guy that has one kidney it was
born that way only reason I know that's
because I went through his medicine
cabinet I was like what is this we would
you find one kidney one kidney I forgot
what it was called but like you know
viagra was there too but literally good
that was fine but you know he's like oh
that one kidney feels like I was born
with one kidney I have to take this I'm
not around that's enough I should be
around death more why why because it's
more normal like I think now humans are
living a little more fake yeah like
we're protected us yeah I think it more
bad [ __ ] what you have to if you're
around death little Mexican culture
celebrates see a little more toes
because it's so much death going on but
it's it's kind of still putting it in
your face like you're not immortal so
you should appreciate the days that
you're living and then obviously pay
respects to well it's a different way of
dealing with death because we always do
what death is like oh I don't want to
even look or anything
yeah that's tired I think you know that
with her life feels like she should
really just like live her life to the
fullest like whatever it is in her 16
years she can't she can't move she's
full - right like a like Anne Frank you
know she has resources and Frank had a
lot of fun with her journal that's true
yeah I like you know write it that's it
and Frank had a lot of fun journal I'm
trying to make it positive dammit he's
an [ __ ]
I like [ __ ] Steve makes it colorful
wait you have to say that with your foot
in the camera though because he's a lot
[ __ ] Street oh my god my karate I can
tell I know that's what my feet usually
look like Oh whenever you dance yeah
you're flexible you are - I know wait do
you want me
there you go that's pretty flexible that
is flexible I know I'm like my pants are
so tight I'm surprised I haven't broken
them yet oh yeah I think minute right I
know thank god they're undone next story
this is [ __ ] depressed it is so sad
wondering if like the people that want
to save her if they're people outside of
her village or maybe even outside of
India and then if her whole street
everyone's like yeah I understand what
their parents like I wouldn't if I had
my daughter had two failed kidneys
that's cool with me too I guess it like
the whole block that thinks that way I
bet because based off of what Joe was
saying I'm probably because I also I
also think it's one of those things
where like when you're poor you got to
be tougher you can't be too sentimental
cuz like you don't have the money to
save your family and maybe they have to
say crazy [ __ ] like that because it will
they can't be too attached
but maybe the good news is that we're
hearing about the story at all because
if it was so except in that area why
would they tell the news about it and
the news with report oh yeah it's not
real oh it's okay what if the story
isn't real it's a hoax yeah what's that
what are they trying that makes me feel
better about this story they're gonna
come up as racist or a [ __ ] about
saying what would you say this is a hard
story to [ __ ] with I'm just saying and
it's sad talk about something else then
what do you want [ __ ] you know mother
Teresa you know how she got all [ __ ]
inspired and [ __ ] so she'd be walking
around like India right and then she saw
like people just dead on the floor and
caca and all that and she saw like a
little flower growing out of a piece of
[ __ ] and she was like man there is
beauty still so like the ability to be
able to see be optimistic in such a
shady situation huh and that's where she
was able to like use that I guess
inspiration to keep loving and helping
those that needed it do you think the
caca makes the flower more beautiful or
less beautiful the contrast you know
it's like the the all right looking girl
in a group of really ugly girls like she
looks super hot that's true it's like
that
I think it's that yeah you
like what nobody's saying like where's a
lot of girls look like pieces of [ __ ]
this one girl looks maybe like an okay
flower so then she looks gorgeous yeah a
beautiful beauty queen yes that's Wow
yeah I understand that yeah it makes
sense I mean can we please in this story
it makes me really sad oh he's so sad
though
yeah we're not quitters because I
struggle from health issues and I have
doctors telling me all this
misinformation and then I have doctors
saying oh you're fine nothing's wrong
with you and another doctors do you have
guilt right now because this person
can't afford it and you can't why spend
a [ __ ] ton of money on health insurance
so it's [ __ ] sucks I'm like all my
money goes there but it's just it's very
hard to have any medical issues
especially being that young yeah it's
just it's a hard thing to process and go
through and I can't imagine being 16
years old and having no support from
your parents I mean it's just like it
hurts my heartstrings
yeah it's great I couldn't poop for like
two weeks straight and I had such a
crazy stomachache it wasn't paid every
[ __ ] day and I would sit on my toilet
pray to [ __ ] Jesus himself and I'd be
like I'll be on fast Christian in a
whole tile world just let me take a [ __ ]
right now
and then I had to go get a [ __ ]
scan and they found a stuck piece of
[ __ ] in my gut and I had to take some
hardcore laxatives and I - it was one of
the most hurtful shits ever dude crazy
that's the second time you've asked God
for a favor he comes through and you've
never fulfilled what you said never
begin second it was when you lost brown
or brown brown away and you were like I
swear to God if he comes back to me I'm
gonna do this this and that and you
never did [ __ ] answered both of my
prayers and I still run away from
Christianity
yeah you do you do promise bro huh he
loosened your [ __ ] up nice I need found
your dog's damned God I made I [ __ ]
made a deal with him and then I backstab
see you in Hell dude it's pretty
gangster though mm why are you gonna be
there I don't know I'm sure I mean
did you scam God - uh I don't think so
I'm just glad your [ __ ] better
though thank you you're welcome
I know what it's like to take a good
[ __ ] yeah
[Music]